good
morning millennials good morning welcome
back to the morning toast happy thursday
i didn't realize i was gonna be doing a
solo good morning good morning oh was i
supposed to do that with you it's okay
it's whatever you want to do good
morning ben you can do it again good
morning
uh good morning jackie today feels like
uh
thursday
uh i was gonna say it feels like it's
been thursday like every day this week
and like i've been waiting for friday so
i'm really happy that it's thursday but
then it just came out that it feels like
thursday and
that's good because it is thursday that
is good that it feels the way it is yes
exactly how are you i'm good welcome to
the toast we haven't done a bunch swan
show together in quite some time in
quite some time so this is going to be
very fun it's going to be great and we
have three days of blunge and swan yes
three days of one gin sponge i can't say
brunch in sponge today it's um you know
the countdown because claudia is out of
town she landed in rome everything's
looking
fabulous you know she's at the chevy
fountain she found friends to take
pictures of her
very happy for her i can confirm that
she's currently napping she's currently
napping that's good yes she she had her
day
she took her scooter through the
fountains
uh and now has retired to her quarters
and is asleep
good i'm happy for her she needs her
sleep she does she she works incredibly
hard and she needs her sleep yeah she
actually i can also confirm that she
slept the entire flight yes i think she
had a very good flight cadence she got
very lucky yeah she she planned it like
she was texting us like asking when
should i no but she but she planned it
poorly but because her flight was
delayed it was excellent that's true you
know are you having fomo that you're not
there yeah
not real fomo
um i'm sad because it's a dear dear
friend's wedding and i really wanted to
be there but
you wanted to be at the toast more gotta
work so yeah and i wanted to be on the
toast so like you just you can't miss
four days in the middle of october
just to gallivant to italy
it just doesn't work like that i
understand this doesn't work like that i
understand i wish though i really do
yeah i do especially i mean well you get
to be here instead and i think
i think that's where you're meant to be
no it's it's great here it's great here
the air conditioning is great this chair
is like [ __ ] the word that claudia
likes to use turned we were just talking
before the show started about these
couches because it's not something that
claudia and i have ever publicly
addressed
but these couches are crazy crazy
couches
oh my god my voice they work for claudia
and i because we're short but anytime
someone of you know
average to big sized comes on the show
it's elf it's that scene in elf with
will ferrell in the classroom yeah
and you know they're just like sinking
they're sinking and now that i'm like
pregnant i notice it more because it's
like everything's a struggle like
getting out of this couch is a struggle
ben wants us to get new couches and i
i don't think we're there yet
but your
your complaint has been filed yeah i'm
just i'm just sliding a bit to the right
like i'm sinking into the corner
so like if at some point in the show i'm
like this
it's not my fault okay i understand yeah
you gotta like use your core yeah hold
yourself upright honestly that's a good
call it's like i'm at the gym yeah just
like holding tight the exact same thing
identical
so we have a great show for you today
ben is going to be helping me deliver
the fast five stories we're going to
recap
we me real houses of beverly hills
reunion you guys i'm really shook and
i'm feeling conflicted i'll i'll talk
you through it when did that show air
last night oh yeah
yeah you had no chance of watching it
with cloudy out of town
i mean i also have no chance of watching
it because you don't respond to your
texts so oh um ben's upset with me
i did specifically text jackie at 5 pm
yesterday saying is there anything i can
watch in preparation for this show you
sent that at 5 p.m jerk
i thought you sent it this morning when
you were having breakfast nope and this
goes further into my complaint that you
are the worst texter on planet earth
okay you did text me after you said you
would bring me an espresso because for
tomorrow's show um i never saw you said
do you want me to watch anything in
preparation i never saw that you said
that
and then you said it again this morning
when you were having breakfast oh good
sorry jackie jackie uh often forgets to
pay her phone bill so it just shuts
and then two days later she pays her
verizon bill and poof no i'm constantly
ignoring ben's texts that one i did not
ignore i actually did not see
it's fine i forgive you but very i would
have answered something like that and i
wouldn't have asked you to watch
anything because without context you
just would have been confused
interesting so regardless i'll i'll
explain it to you and i watch the season
premiere of winterhouse which is summer
house
southern charm go to vermont for 17 days
with some of their non-famous friends
who are now going to be they go together
they all go into one house it's like 12
people one house vermont interesting yes
and they go for 17 days and they film
the 17 days and they cut it up into a
show yep that they were desperate for
content in covid so that was the idea
they came up with pretty good idea we'll
talk about the execution in the tv recap
segment because i'm not convinced and i
didn't realize that like this wasn't
where craig and paige fell in love
and that's why i tuned in to like see
their love blossom but i don't think
they even talk to each other the entire
show so that's really frustrating
sounds frustrating yeah cool anyways
we'll get to all of that
i mean we could jump right into the past
five stories but it seems premature it
seems too early yeah so
i mean let's talk about you how are you
doing how's spritz society doing i'm
doing excellent spirit society is great
um we actually received a 95 out of a
hundred on purewow yesterday wow can you
tell us what that means yeah purewow
gave us like an unbelievable
unbelievable write-up where they scored
taste convenience quality
and they scored us a 95 out of 100 20
out of 20 for taste they said that the
grapefruit could replace a paloma
wow i'm just saying
that's pretty crazy that's big stuff
that's pretty crazy so spritz is going
great we need to get you in a photo
shoot like we need
we need jackie in a winter photo shoot i
would love that bump and all bump and
all okay we could stack the boxes on
your bump like we could you could be
like a circus like you know like a
circus actually a circus act exactly i
don't know if that's what you want out
of your bump but i don't know if that's
what the bump is for but any way i can
help push product yeah no i mean
just just you and just you and stuff and
as always code toast for ten percent off
of spritz society yes
society.com toast
yeah
um
yeah it's going great it's fun it's just
like
what a what a wild ride so glad to hear
that i was actually thinking about you
last night because i watched the new
york city mayoral debate
which aired last night i don't know if
anybody knew that i just happened to
stumble upon it and it was just very
exciting you know because regardless of
who wins
bill de blasio will no longer be mayor
and that is very exciting for the city
for you sorry for the people
and i wanted to see you as i discuss
this very important topic
whoever wins is better who i agree
that's the best part that's the best
part it's it's looking up no matter how
you slice it i think you could literally
have a five-year-old run
and go in office and just like sit there
and smile and it would be better yeah
yeah yeah so um but you were giving me
some of your takes on last night's
mayoral debate well i just said how are
you feeling i'm feeling optimistic
honestly i well one i really don't think
it can get worse i don't want to jinx it
you know like you think it doesn't get
worse and then it does but i really
think that we have two strong candidates
they were talking some some good ideas
last night and i think it's it's going
to be looking up for new york city it's
impossible that it gets worse unless we
literally elect adolf hitler and we go
into like 1940s germany for the jews
that really is i know it's a hot take
there are people pissing and [ __ ] in
the streets as of this morning somebody
sent me a video every day i get this
like do you guess i get me i get it
it's all my dm's are all de blasio are
they all like flooded with images of
like new york city trash it's trash but
it's also news so this morning okay
there was a couple that had sex on the
subway okay um and by the way the the
headline was so funny it's like
unvaccinated and unmasked couple has sex
on the subway it's like
would it not have been news if they were
not if they were vaccinated and masked
so if they're vaccinated in mass but
they're having sex on the subway that's
fine that's good very strange um but yes
having sex on the subway and somebody
sent me it's like a video of them like
pumping on the subway uh saying ben you
need to run for mayor and it's like
it's time you think it's time i think
it's not time
one day i would love to okay it's not
time it's good to have dreams it's good
to have dreams it's a dream just like
what the hell are they doing what's he
doing i don't know what is he doing it i
don't know it's a train wreck
for the first time yesterday so i went
to the nick game last night
and i went down through
times square i guess i hadn't been
through times square in like
six months
the lights are blinding like you need to
wear sunglasses yeah and honestly there
needs to be like a warning at 50th
street like beware of migraines like as
you cross down because it's such a it's
such different lighting and all of a
sudden you're just smacked in the face
by lg i guess that's like an irrelevant
comment but just whoever runs for may or
next you need to get glasses that have
like auto shades transitions transition
lenses because this is something that
clearly
affects you yeah that is just like i'm
not i'm not willing to be that big of a
loser
and like i i'm sorry if i am the guy
with transition lenses the problem with
transition lenses is when you're when
you're caught in the middle of the two
so like there's like a timer
when you're mid transition and somebody
catches you you look just so special
okay i just i want to say a few things
one i think that you could pull it off
you know you wear crocs like you like
ugly things
oh my god you have terrible fashion
sense
so like you could make transition lunges
lens is cool and i do think like
transition lens is worth at their most
embarrassing like when you're in the
playground you know and your parents
pick them out for you and you're going
inside and everybody's lenses
you know like but if you're making the
choice as a grown man
i think you have to just own it lisa own
it it's actually such a good call every
parent that puts their five-year-old in
transition lenses should be shot on the
spot it's so mean they are those poor
kids i'm crazy those four kids are
ruined okay what's how what percentage
of kids do you think were punched in the
face on the playground that wore
transition lenses i don't know because i
never wore glasses growing up so i don't
associate with glasses problems like
you i only know transition lenses are
illusory from like you
other people telling me jackie but wait
let me ask you what you know they're
losing not from me i think it's a cool
piece of technology okay let me ask you
what's worse
for a kid on the playground
lenses or like the glasses that have the
little clip of sunglasses
like i know what you're talking about
glasses 100 transition lenses they are
so so sad for poor little johnny who's
being beaten up by chuck like big fat
chuck as he comes down the slide and
chuck's just waiting for him and he
pounds him into the ground but what if
big fat chuck was wearing transition
lenses big fat chuck then would not be
big fat chuck
big fat chuck would be like just like
that sad fat kid that's like now a
member of the chess club his life
completely changes a parent changes
their child's life when they put him in
transition lenses but you could be the
pioneer
for transitioning transition lenses i
could and you so many kids would look up
to you i could you could make them cool
like on your instagram story and then
they would they would come home from
getting picked on they'd watch your
story and then be like ben wears
transition lenses it's okay i could i
don't know if that's gonna be like the
hill that i'm gonna die on and like what
i'm gonna pioneer
like i think i'm down to pioneer
something for today's youth uh i don't
think it's gonna be transition lenses i
think they need to be retired
uh honestly i think that they it should
be like smoking you can't wear
transition lenses until you're 18 and
you can make the choice for yourself and
you have to like wear a little your
parents can't force you to wear
transition lenses wow you feel really
strongly about this yeah it's just not
nice
okay it's like naming your daughter
bertha
well we could
you could think about it just think
about what i've proposed i'll think
about it next time you're going through
times square okay
i'll think about it okay cool cool well
i guess without now without further ado
yes we could get into
the
story that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning tonight
we do have a machine that makes this i
know but i prefer it and did i beat it
you did beat the machine yeah
well that should be a game beat the
machine yeah and you won yeah nice
of transition lenses
you guys should make you know those uh
tick tock snapchat filters where you
have to time it up perfectly
yes you're like when you do the clap
yeah and you have to time it to the
second you should do it with the bite
okay oh my god i'm a marketing genius
thank you for this great idea thank you
for this great idea i think that the
show is just gonna take off with that
and
beat the crunch beat the crunch oh my
god it's actually so good that's really
cute yeah okay well let's get into the
fast side stories but i do need to let
you know that today's episode is brought
to you by bruce
okay bruce is the official
toothbrush of the morning toast the
toothbrush of the morning toothbrush yes
toothbrush we love bruce i've been
brushing for over a year my teeth my
shiny teeth and me are just on and
poppin and you need to get bruce not
only is it the best toothbrush electric
toothbrush on the market it's affordable
it has six unique modes to customize
your brushing experience a four
four-week battery life with a magnetic
charging stand and a compact travel case
i personally have my home brush and my
travel brush and there's it's just a
level of luxury that wow i can't even
explain you get a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again you're not using like a brush
that you've been using for months and
months because that's pretty nasty plus
it has a sleek design
they have modern aesthetically pleasing
trend driven colors for my home
toothbrush i have a light pink and for
my travel toothbrush i have a mauve and
it's just sickening really this color
but you could also get black if you you
know like a uniform palette whatever
whatever floats your boat bruce has the
toothbrush for you so get 15
off your brush toothbrush kit and refill
plan when you use promo code toast at
bruce.com toast that's 15 off using
promo code toast at b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com slash toast get your teeth right
smile is gleaming with bruce everything
of the story truly
you mentioned that you have both a
at home toothbrush
and a travel toothbrush i do
i
thought maybe i'm just totally alone in
this
i buy a toothbrush
everywhere i go on vacation so i i don't
travel with a toothbrush
i
i used to be like that yeah i actually
could one-up you in an even worse
capacity
i used to not bring a toothbrush and i
would just use zax when we would travel
oh yeah
but then bruce came out with their new
trend driven seasonal colors and i got a
second bruce and i was like you know
what i'm gonna be proactive i'm putting
this in my compact for like with all my
travel
bottles and stuff that way i always have
a toothbrush with me when i travel yeah
that's pretty good no and it's amazing
and that way my teeth don't hover you
also don't spend the amount of money
that i spend on toothbrushes every year
because i just buy them wherever i go i
spend a lot of money in toothbrushes
yeah no it's it's everything of the sort
okay let's get into the stories because
we have a nice array of stories
first up an update in the gabby potito
case human remains have been found in
the search for brian laundry along with
his backpack and notebook authorities
searching a florida park for brian
laundry have discovered human remains
along with a backpack and notebook
belonging to the 23 year old fugitive
people confirms michael mcpherson of fbi
tampa announced the news during a
wednesday press conference he did not
confirm whether the remains found in the
park were laundries the area in which
the remains were found had previously
been underwater mcpherson said an
evidence response team is on the scene
and likely will be there for days
so this is pretty
you know suspect and also interesting
and this is the first update that we've
had in a while
i do feel like people i'm not the expert
on on this case you know claudia and i
will say we're not the true crime
podcast queens that so many others are
but i think a lot of people are finding
this to be quite suspect and they're not
convinced
what do you think have you been
following this case
following is a strong strong word
i'm aware of this case
okay i'm aware
i think that and i even mentioned it to
you this morning
i think that until they confirm that
it's his remains
it's like it's us it's us i agree like
you find how long has you been missing
he's been missing since september 13th
so over
almost
a month and a half got it and we just
find his backpack and his
stuff and some things like like
perfectly next to
his remains not his even i'm saying
perfectly next to remains like haven't
they been searching that park night and
day forever well it was apparently
underwater
oh so it just came up
it seems seems like a movie yeah i i'm
not convinced we'll see the remains you
know they'll test them and we'll see
if they are a match
i'm not convinced that this is where the
story ends though right
yeah i mean regardless terrible story
yes
but it is
optimistic to have an update because we
hadn't heard much in a while wasn't
wasn't the thinking if i'm remembering
this case correctly that he
killed his girlfriend yeah
allegedly perhaps
but then he
drowned in a river
he
allegedly could have potentially um
killed his girlfriend then he went back
home to florida
and like didn't report her missing even
though they were like on a road trip
together
and then you know that started to look
quite sus and then he went missing but i
think intentionally
he intentionally went missing and killed
himself is the thought no i don't know
about that
i'm just saying like this might just
okay
he could be hiding now this makes more
sense this could be someone else's
remains it seems like these are
definitely somebody else's remains he
put the backpack and jacket there
so that backpack and jacket there so it
would seem like yeah he's there but
really he's parting it up in
some other country yeah he's fled the
scene that's my take
without having much information
but also people also think like his
parents are covering for him there's a
lot of uh
possibilities but he's like the most
wanted man in
damn america right now damn all right so
then they should probably check the
remains yeah i think that would be a
good place to start yeah i think i think
that they're on it okay so we'll keep
you posted okay cool but it's some new
news i know claudia was getting
frustrated that we hadn't you know
nothing had turned up yet ah yeah okay
well it seems like nothing is turned up
in general
perhaps potentially yeah this is like
the
the way to new news we're on we're on
the ship it hasn't docked yeah no and a
lot of ships haven't docked i'm sure
you've seen no the ships are out at sea
the ships are out at sea oh yeah
are you ready for our next story of
course some exciting tv news khloe
kardashian reveals a possible premiere
date for their family's new hulu show
chloe um went on the ellen degeneres
show and teased when the new reality
show will potentially hit hulu when host
ellen asked when the new show might
premiere chloe replied i think in a few
months either end of january early
february ellen said that's fast she said
really fast that's the beauty of hulo
we're streaming and we get to have a
much quicker turnaround than previously
we're really excited okay this is
something claudia and i have been
really highly anticipating and i just
assumed that like with the hulu show it
was like never going to come out and we
would just never see it i don't know why
but claudia was saying that we actually
would probably get it in a quicker
turnaround time than we used to get
keeping up on me
so this is so exciting yes sorry i was
just cracking my neck i happen to love
that show i find it very entertaining
and i really did like i know some people
didn't like it
it got so incredibly premium in terms of
the video quality as the seasons went on
like the last keeping up with the
kardashians seasons were so high def
yeah i just think it's a very good
reality show clearly well-funded and i
assume that the hulu version will be
even more premium because
yeah by the way new hulu nulu
new okay
yeah we'll we'll add that to one of your
free ideas yeah i think we should do and
the crunch uh
bar okay we'll start we'll keep a list
okay cool um also want to get your take
because i'm sure you saw that courtney
and travis got engaged
and how do you feel like travis is one
of your emo kings now i feel awesome i
feel awesome because
i really feel like and i've i've been
reading i i'm actually quite educated on
this topic
i
was reading uh courtney's comments under
their
uh engagement
announcement and a lot of people are
saying that like he changed her she only
wears black and it's like isn't it
possible that travis barker like all of
the other
just like great pop punk
emo
uh people just inspire
people to be themselves like isn't it
this was always the real courtney
or she's just happy in general like i
think that he takes so much societal
pressure off of her by being somebody
that is
fully tatted in a band like doing his
thing like he just he does what he wants
he doesn't like travis barker is like
the the pinnacle of
just self-confidence and not doing
things for the wrong reasons and i feel
like he's pushed that on to courtney
maybe for the first time in her life
like she's
being
the person like throughout all of the
seasons especially the most recent ones
the common thread is she feels like
she's being forced to do things that she
doesn't want to do she's being forced to
do the show she's being forced to do
these photo shoots and like finally it's
not her it's not her like this seems
like it's her like she's found somebody
that isn't dying to be on the show like
isn't isn't dying to just like take her
fame right he's so damn famous and
awesome in his in his own right of
course he's gonna benefit from this but
um i think that she
i think it's amazing and i think that
she's in a really great place it seems
like that's so beautiful ben i really
like your take on that i would agree
with you and i think it's just you know
they've been together for like nine
months and they got engaged she was with
scott for like almost 10 years and like
wouldn't marry him and it's like
because she knows herself and she knows
what she was looking for and she found
it it wasn't a matter of like time or
you know not long enough it was just
like a feeling and i think she's found
that feeling yeah for somebody like her
she doesn't want somebody that's just
gonna just like
be the exact same person that the rest
of her family is like i think that she
wants her own life and like i think he
gives her that like separate
life away from just yeah she has her her
own thing now has her own thing and
she's never had her own thing
yeah i i hear you i think you're you're
spitting facts okay cool
i think i think it's really beautiful
okay thank you are you ready for our
next story i am
simone biles gets emotional discussing
the twisties on the today show she said
i'm still scared to do gymnastics so
simone went on the today show and she's
sharing insight into her personal
struggle struggles during this year's
summer games in tokyo she removed
herself from four out of five events due
to a case of the twisties a disorienting
condition athletes can experience when
they lose air awareness putting them at
risk for injury when they land she
explained at the time that she withdrew
from the competition to focus on her
mental health saying on social media
that her mind and body are simply not in
sync while appearing on the today show
today biles got emotional with host hoda
as she expressed frustration and seeing
other athletes able to perform moves she
no longer can hoda asked whether bile
still experiences the twisties while
performing on the road for the athleta
presents gold over america tour
alongside other top gymnasts she said i
don't twist i do my signature moves on
the floor but that's never affected me
everything else just like weighs so
heavy and i watch the girls do it and
it's just it's not the same
hoda asked if that's weird and she said
yeah to do something that i've done
forever and just not be able to do it
because of everything i've gone through
is really crazy because i love this
sport so much but it's hard i'm sorry
and i don't think people understand the
magnitude of what i go through
it's a very sad story i'll tell you why
it's so sad for me
uh
just to bring in some more sports
because i know you guys don't get enough
sports and by the way there are a lot of
sporty toasters and i actually saw we
got a question for you um let's talk
about simone and then we'll do that and
then we'll do our official sports
segment but for
the people watching that like sports
there's a basketball player his name is
markelle fultz
incredible in college was drafted number
one
forgot how to shoot
came to the nba and forgot how to shoot
he was an unbelievable shooter they
retrained him to shoot and his form was
never the same and he stinks
and that is just i think
what's sort of happening here like well
when you say forgot how to shoot like
what does that mean his like i think
it's similar to the twisties like i
think you just get in your own head and
all of a sudden you just can't do what
you did yeah like you're there's mental
blockers that are stopping you from
performing at your best yeah and i think
i remember like i mean obviously the
story from the olympics and like
the way that it came out it was so
mental health focused that she just quit
because of her mental health the
twisties are super dangerous like i
think about that all the time if you're
not all the time i'm not always thinking
about this but i think about it
occasionally and it's like when you jump
up and you're spinning your heads like
yeah you could you could die like you
could fall on your head and snap your
neck yeah so if you're uncomfortable in
the air you definitely should not be
performing that trick yeah and to hear
that she's still going through that
really sucks yeah because it's i have a
feeling it's
impossible to get out of at least
judging by the markelle fultz example
once you sort of lose it you lose it oh
i mean i i i don't know and
it'll be interesting to see i mean i
don't think she'll be competing again
just because like she's already done so
much and she doesn't need to and i think
i think since the olympics so much of
the other like mental
elements that were
playing a part in her
performance have really come to light
like especially you know last month with
um the larry nassar hearing in uh
congress and all of the girls speaking
and like how she really felt
this responsibility to still show up to
the olympics to remind usa gymnastics
like there are still victims of larry
nassar who are here and like we need
justice and that is so much pressure to
put on yourself and i think
i think people even now have more of an
understanding of what she might have
been going through in tokyo
for sure and so i'm
i'm glad that she's providing even more
clarity but it's it's a very
it's very sad very sad because she
i mean she is amazing but she was an
amazing gymnast yeah the goat the goat
the goat
um
yeah well
get well soon yeah i mean i i hope i
hope she returns to form but it's it's
interesting it's like
does she really retire
on this
like i know she's super decorated but
like if it was me i would do everything
that i could
to try and go out the way that i wanted
to go out so i'm sure that she will
perform again because
well she's performing on this tour she
said um and she's like just doing tricks
that don't require twists so they're not
things that she could get twisties doing
um but i'm sure i think she has a long
career ahead of her in in other areas
yes
welcome to the construction site that is
the morning toast that happens sometimes
we do have some sports questions for you
i want to launch into a sports segment
quickly and it's brought to you by
organifi organifi is a line of organic
superfood blends that offers plant-based
nutrition made with high quality
ingredients each organifi blend is
science-backed to craft the most
effective doses with ingredients that
are organic and free of fillers and
contain less than three grams of sugar
per serving like organifi green juice
with essential superfoods and a clinical
dose of ashwagandha it helps reduce
stress and support healthy cortisol
levels or organifi gold a superfood tea
that
supports rest and relaxation so you can
wake up feeling refreshed
each organifi blend is easy to use by
simply mixing it with water or your
favorite beverage while on the go and
they don't compromise quality for taste
organifi takes pride in offering the
best tasting superfood products on the
market that worked out to less than
three dollars a day you can experience
organifi's high quality superfoods
without breaking the bank go to
organifi.com toast and use our code
toast for 20 off your order that's o r g
a n i f i dot com backslash toast and
use code toast for 20 off any item
enjoy okay this was the question that we
got for you because last week claudia
and i were discussing our super bowl
predictions
and
as it stands right now who do you think
will be playing each other in the super
bowl
who will be playing each other in the
super mm-hmm
that's a tough tough question yeah
there's you know it's just speculation
claudia said bills versus bucks
bills bucks that's a very
possible product that's what people said
i said seahawks vs bucks
that is a very difficult are they in the
same day they are in the same division
yeah so that's that's so that's
impossible zach said it's impossible but
i also think that something will happen
that will force two teams in the same
division to play against interesting so
that is uh one of the worst stakes i've
ever heard
that is that is actually impossible okay
every team that i think of is in the
same division yeah so that's why i was
bringing out my phone let me just give
you a couple of teams that you can pick
from okay okay so
uh afc
buffalo new england
uh sorry bills patriots jets
uh dolphins any of them do you like any
of them
um claudia took the bills and i think
they're having a nice go of it i don't
like any of them okay all right what
about the panthers
could they the panthers are just not
good it's just about even with christian
mccaffrey yeah and his love for olivia
culpo yeah it's just not good
okay it's just not good okay all right
i'm making my bold take just because i
love actually oh wait sorry we're doing
your take uh okay
ravens bengals steelers browns
titans colts
texans jaguars chargers raiders
broncos chiefs
one of those similar like any of those
maybe i'll take the raiders raiders by
the way
i'm a raiders fan i don't know if you
knew that they're las vegas right las
vegas and where and the super bowl this
year is
we were just it's in l.a
yes
okay and you saw the lineup for the
halftime show no
the halftime show is a medley of snoop
dogg eminem hold on let me why can't
they get artists that aren't
like
old
no and also claudia and i were saying
like i don't like a medley i like a
one-star shirt i love eminem i'm excited
for it but like snoop eminem dr dre mary
j blige ken kendrick lamar ooh it's
interesting yeah they're doing like a
little festival thing it's interesting
i like to pick the raiders by the way
okay so raiders versus bucks is that
something yeah raiders box let's go with
that i'll go with that too
wow
raiders bucks you guys you heard it here
first and everybody's going to be
confused like ben why are you in new
york and rooting for the raiders we
didn't say rooting for i mean no i root
for the raiders for sure but these picks
are just based on what i'm seeing yeah
okay well they're not based on what
you're saying well i do see
i do see you know the cowboy game any
time it's on because it's like in the
sacks watching and i think the cowboys
are you know
they stink they leave a lot to be
desired yeah and so i judge what other
team they're playing like are they worse
than the cowboys or are they okay yeah
or did or was it a landslide the raiders
fun team to pick it's good okay so
you're a raiders fan that's your number
one team raiders are my number one team
i was a giants fan i was the truth is
and everyone's gonna say you can't
switch you can switch when you're a
knicks fan
when you're a knicks fan
you only see losing seasons i cannot
spend money every single year and give
my heart to multiple new york franchises
that let me down i need to root for one
winner so i picked the raiders they felt
like they were on the up and up a couple
of years ago now they're in vegas derek
carr darren waller josh jacobs
the team is good the team is good and
fun okay not great by the way i have a
question there's a solid chance they
don't make the the super bowl i'm just
letting you know that's okay it's so i
don't know
personally it's just like fun to have
claudia's is so good how did she do her
research no she didn't by the way bill's
box like will be the super bowl wow
that's pretty nuts
um
no i was going to ask you so new york is
like you know the greatest city in the
world allegedly
yeah sure
why are the sports teams like comically
bad in every category except for the
yankees i think that they're putting
some respect on the city uh
the yankees
have historically spent the most money
like in the history of sports to remain
competitive and that's why the yankees
always do well even the yankees though
have been in a bit of a dry spell like
they're they're still they win games
they have great teams but they got
knocked out in the wild card game like
they didn't even make technically make
the playoffs this year
uh
the mets i mean were huge pete alonso
fans here love him dear friend the mets
had a great team didn't make the
playoffs the giants stink the jets stink
the knicks are finally the knicks by the
way might be the best new york team
right now right now
they won last night it was crazy uh
the brooklyn nets uh
can can all drown so we don't talk about
them uh on this show okay there's way
too much going on there they're a super
team that lives in brooklyn i don't even
consider
brooklyn is it's just
just go over there okay so then what
about like the rangers
uh i don't follow enough hockey i have
to assume they're good the rangers are
always the rangers are always
responsible they're always respectable
but back to the giants and jets
one
we crammed them into the same stadium it
can't be easy to do that they just
alternate games in the same stadium
nobody really has a home yeah i think
it's difficult to share a home yeah
there's no home court advantage because
they share a home i think it's very i
think it's very difficult and strange
it's like if the cowboys and panthers
played in the same stadium yeah it's
weird that is weird i didn't realize
that yeah met life is just jets and
giants i didn't realize that was the
situation very odd and i think that that
might might hurt them no one's working
on building a new stadium no there's
always a new stadium there should be but
they just built metlife and it was like
a trillion dollars so now i don't see a
new stadium coming they both have young
quarterbacks zach wilson daniel jones
rookie quarterbacks young quarterbacks
it's just tough to win with them unless
they're like really amazing you know who
has a nice quarterback
the bills uh josh allen's amazing i said
i was watching a package on him yeah and
he was a package like just you know he
was being interviewed by a reporter like
they went you know is that what they
call it though it was just like a little
package of like josh allen promo did
they make that up did you make that up
no no it's like a chair it's an industry
term that's a term industry term yeah it
was like a package that they did some
like josh allen propaganda but it was
he's very very good yeah no he he seemed
like he had a good head on his shoulders
and i think that's important yeah
and he's just like good at football like
and that's important too yeah that's
probably the most important
as opposed to having a good head on the
shoulder i think they go hand in hand
they do no if you can have both
total package total package um
but yeah the the jets and giants yeah
play in the same stadium young
quarterbacks
great fan bases but in the end of the
day it's just
maybe the pressures of new york are just
getting to them i think the pressures of
new york got to the knicks for a long
time until they had a really great coach
i just came in
tom thibodeau
he was the coach of the bulls the old
bowls
like really just known for being a
tough coach yeah no [ __ ] i think in
new york it's very easy to sort of lose
yourself go to the clubs yeah i think
there's a few cities like where that
where that could happen to some of the
players yeah and i think new york is one
of them and i think there are probably
other cities that have the opposite
effect you know that are really
grounding very like family oriented
that's why the san antonio spurs have
been like the best the most consistent
team for the last 25 years because of
the environment yeah greg popovich was
their coach
and created a wholesome environment in
san antonio texas where these guys just
love to play basketball and they won
like consistently over 70 of their games
for 20 straight years that's such a
beautiful story have they made a movie
about that uh they should they should
the wholesomeness of san antonio yeah
even though i don't think that that's
really what it is like i think greg
popovich was like uh
no but like whatever he was doing like
oh he was he was doing great stuff it
could be like the next money ball yeah
and his team i mean there's definitely a
movie a movie there yeah free idea yeah
that's the third free idea okay ready
for our next story it's actually some
news about you that you spoiled earlier
in the show
but
pure wow oh yeah gave sports society and
95 out of 100
on their pure wow charts for aesthetics
they measure aesthetics taste quality
functionality and value yep do you want
to go through all the scores yeah we can
go through all the scores value we got
17 out of 20 yep functionality 20 out of
20 quality 19 out of 20 aesthetics 20
out of 20 taste 19 out of 20 for a total
of 95 out of 100 that's an a it's an a
yeah it's my first a
i can say that i very rarely in my life
have gotten a 95 out of 100 unless i
cheated um and this is just wonderful
press that was really really exciting
you love to hear it and also because you
know
until you order the cans you can't
really taste the product so it is
valuable to hear from other people on
their experience with the taste and for
the customers yeah 100 so
pure wow endorsed this is good tasting
stuff i'm really so excited i'm going to
have to bring a
a a case with me to the hospital i was
going to say this is going to be like
the first thing i do i don't know if i
could actually do it because with like
breastfeeding and stuff like that i
might have to wait no but we're gonna
throw you a sickening
welcome back to drinking party okay and
you're gonna need to have a migraine
pill on hand because you're gonna get a
terrible headache i just know you okay
but oh i was thinking that we'll get
back to the purewow thing
i got targeted for these holistic beads
that you like put on your ear and
pressure points that you like apparently
it's some ancient medicine that really
helps with migraines i'm going to send
it to you well you know i don't want to
jinx anything have you been good things
have been good first trimester and my
headache doctor actually told me that
this would happen she said that women
who have migraines do really well in the
second and third trimester she didn't
talk about the first so i was like okay
it must be bad first trimester was
blindingly painful
but i don't want to jinx it knock on mud
please like don't come for me
it's been
okay
and
i do have some natural remedies and i've
added magnesium and b12 into my vitamin
lineup and i think that's really helped
but also
i realized that i i clenched my jaw so
tightly when i was sleeping and i used
then i started to wear night guards
because also my teeth shift and
i thought the night guards were helping
i think that they were but i was still
clenching so hard and so now i've
started to relax like be really mindful
of my jaw when i sleep and i don't wake
up with the migraines that i used to
i don't know if it's just because like
if that has nothing to do with anything
but
things have been really quiet that's
good and you're a migraine sufferer i
was gonna say i feel like you absolutely
never talk about your headaches on the
show you do i don't talk about them on
the show if i have one on the show i
like let everyone know that's why i like
having a watery eye or like i'm looking
like yeah like like frowny
um
no but i'm always talking about my
headaches yeah i mean we both have very
hazely eyes you think it has to do with
eyes i'm 100 sure that true migraines
that where we're sensitive to lights
are eye color for sure
that's a fact you can google it it
sounds like another case for transition
lenses yeah no by the way 100 you're
right and i'm just like not dying on
that hill as i already mentioned okay um
but
yeah so those beads are those beads are
pretty good for uh
i also noticed i i think the people have
if you follow me on instagram uh you'll
know that i've started to wear breathe
right strips
we did you know theo showed up the other
day i know with it in his [ __ ] foot i
wanted to kill myself with a breathe
right strip in his foot he was eating
his foot and we're like okay sometimes
i've seen brewer like eat his foot must
be tasty
and then he started chewing on something
and we're like oh he got something out
of his foot and it was pops breathe
right straight
uh first of all theo i am so sorry
second of all you're so resourceful
like he he managed to get what was
bothering him out of his own foot he
didn't need us to kill her he's a he's a
healer yeah he is how is due today uh
he's wonderful he's wonderful he's
currently on a walk gallivanting across
the city probably just ate somebody
else's duty and he's just like he's just
like having a great time probably a
human yeah for sure for sure
um
i think we were talking about purewow
and then we got uh sort of off track but
yeah the the only thing that i want to
say first of all thank you pirouel for
the honest and wonderful review uh my
personal favorite flavors are grapefruit
and pineapple orange is still delicious
and so is lemon um
but grapefruit got a 20 out of 20. wow
wow and honestly this shit's going to
win an award and if you haven't tried it
you've got it you really have to like
the
we would never make a product
you can attest to this that we didn't
want to drink all the time yeah claudia
does not drink
any hard seltzer anymore
because we made something that she
wanted to drink and the end of the day
spritz society is that drink so just
just wanted everybody to know
you can go
sprit society.com use code toast 10 off
but also
not
so soon
but soon you'll be able to buy it in
some local stores ooh that's exciting
which is pretty exciting yeah that'll be
fun um it is it it's i mean
it's all fun but yes purewow thank you
appreciate it awesome well let's get
into our fifth and final story which
will lead into our tv recap lisa arena
said that scott disick's dm oh you know
we do this thing here at the show
we do a song oh
for the final story
and i do think that you could provide
value okay you want me to sing it no no
oh
do you have
okay so hold your triangle at the top
everyone you can lower the volume right
now
and it goes like this
it's the final story
[Music]
da
thank you very much doesn't that feel
good it does honestly uh in another life
i could have been a cantor i did the
seventh bracha at your wedding you did i
did the seventh brock at olivia's
wedding
and i was asked to do the seventh bracha
at my dear friend matthew hardoon's
wedding uh marrying his lovely bride
adina safty so
that's not only family asking me that's
because i'm known in the trades
as a great cantor no you you are and i
definitely i don't know if you because
you don't watch your show um
by the way yeah no no it's fine but we
do have you know some plans for you
for like an upcoming bris oh you know
we're gonna put you to work oh nice and
also i feel like in another life you and
claudia could have made like the most
beautiful cantorial duo totally oh you
know i'm so sad you've missed your that
would have been so nice like 3 000 years
ago we would have been
it you but why not today you guys could
be the digital canters yeah i think that
that would have a similar hit to the
transition lenses on
the digital cameras who wear transition
lenses yeah no it's it's a good it's
good again i'm not going to die on it
okay think about it but you'll think
about it i'll think about it but so i
just want to make sure i'm not being
asked to do any
moral duties no claudia offered your
moyal duties got it so she offered my
s you're snipping dude not the snip yeah
when was that um that was like five
years ago no that was like two or three
years ago first toe studio interesting
cool yeah good times great times um
i'm sure that baby of the burst you went
to is like three years old now for sure
i'm trying to remember whose baby it was
yeah but yeah i'm i'm happy to perform
any
singing duties i wasn't doing any
snipping we'll talk about the run of
show okay cool um
so now it's time for our fifth and final
story
now i feel prepared too to get into that
story which is that lisa rinna shared
last night on the real houses beverly
hills
reunion part two that scott disick's dms
played a role in the amelia hamlin
breakup so scott disick was dating
amelia hamlin do you know who that is
that is lisa arena's daughter correct
correct yes i know a lot about this this
franchise oh yes you do claudia has
shared that with us so they were dating
for almost a year and um nobody
absolutely no one was here for it
not a soul yeah including like her own
parents what not and then they broke up
around the same time that scott sent
that dm to eunice do you see that story
you know who eunice is
like
is he in like
benjamin's yes yes courtney's ex is
eunice and they dated what courtney and
him dated yeah for like a long time oh i
didn't know that it was not it i know so
he dm'd eunice scott disick damn junior
is a picture of one of the pictures of
courtney and travis like making out on a
boat like in bathing suits like very you
know um pda
and he's like yo what's up with this
girl
and
eunice likes responded something like
she could do what she wants then he
screenshotted it and put it on a story
so everyone saw that like scott was like
damning eunice talking about courtney
including his girlfriend at the time
amelia
and now and then
a few days later it came out that they
broke up and
it seemed like one had to do with the
other and so lisa rena is confirming
that it did have
something to do with that that's a crazy
story it was really crazy it was
shocking especially because um why is
why is yoon eunice such a snitch
that's like well i think it looks like
an opportunity for him to come off
looking really good you know because he
like then sent a very you know
appropriate response
and then yeah because he was putting it
online right that's crazy i know but how
did i miss that story i don't know it's
also crazy that scott would reach out to
him
especially because like scott is still a
member of the family yeah like i guess
but like dms are like they're not meant
to be screenshoted and posted they're
much like texts that's crazy be careful
but they're not friends they didn't have
any previous dns like oh they're oh
they're not friends they're not friends
oh so then
he was just like being a [ __ ] starter
that's weird yeah it was very weird the
whole thing's weird i know what an odd
story
that's what we do here we share odd
stories holy crap so i'm perplexed we
got a little bit of tea from lisa arena
last night she was absolutely living for
it and we're gonna get into the tv recap
that is brought to you
by an
amazing company called fast growing
trees
when is the perfect time to plant trees
and shrubs big bucks so our experts will
tell you any time or a great question
but the best time to plant
is actually fall which means now is the
time to go to fastgrowingtrees.com
you can skip the big box stores
and head to fastgrowingtrees.com the
world's largest online nursery no more
waiting in lines messy cars and digging
through a lackluster selection just go
to fastgrowingtrees.com and choose from
thousands of varieties of trees shrubs
and plants expertly curated to thrive in
your area and delivered to your door in
one or two days whether you're looking
for shade privacy fruit trees or just
added color for your yard every plant is
shipped with a well-developed root
system ready to explode with new growth
come spring this is an amazing company
that makes you know getting
landscaping and all of these different
elements for your home so much easier at
fastgrowingtrees.com there's a better
way to buy trees and shrubs plants for
your home and yard it's
fastgrowingtrees.com
now through november 30th going go to
fastgrowingtrees.com
toast for 15 off that's 15 off at fast
growing trees
toast
fastgrowingtrees.com slash toast
it is a game changer in the industry
now that's a pretty great url yeah
fastgrowingtrees.com really yeah
growing trees that grow fast cool
real housewives of beverly hills reunion
part two
recap let's get into it it was very much
so i'm actually appreciating what
they're doing in this reunion usually
it's a four-part reunion usually we get
three on a season with some tea so this
is a very big one because of the erica
girardi situation i'm sure you're
familiar
so usually they save all of the tea for
the last episode of the reunion but it
seems as though andy is asking questions
like in between other segments so we're
getting like erica stuff every episode
and housewives drama
so i actually i've been very
i don't know what the word is but i've
been very
suspicious of erica most of the season
ever since we saw like housewife and the
hustler and you know we've been
hearing about what tom was allegedly
doing i
i really you know
was not keen on on her i
still don't know what i believe but i do
believe that erica is
doing a great job in this reunion she is
crawling out of this whole she is she's
a fighter and i think that she made some
fair points
and she answered really every question
that she could there was only one
question that she couldn't answer which
was how she got the money to even like
leave tom when she said like she gave
him all of her paychecks from the show
and everything that she ever made like
he handled for her so she didn't like
have credit cards that he didn't he
would just you know if she left he would
cancel her credit cards so andy asked
like so how did you get money to like
rent a house and a car and all these
things and she said she couldn't share
because i has to do with her divorce
proceeding which
i can understand the only question that
i felt like she skirted which has been a
big question for me
she's always said she was married to tom
for 20 years you know they got married
when she was 27 and he was 60. so
there's always been this really big age
difference between them and she's
loved him for 20 years and she said i
thought i was going to hold this man's
hand until he died and now she's blaming
a lot of the degeneration of their
marriage on his mental health mental
deterioration she said that he has you
know signs of dementia and alzheimer's
and
um he became a really difficult person
to
be married to and andy asked her like
you know
you said you would be with tom till the
end now things are getting difficult and
you leave him just as he needs you just
as he's like getting sick and
deteriorating and she went into the
story of how when he crashed his car she
she found him and took the pictures and
took him to the hospital and called all
these doctors asking for advice
but that didn't answer the question of
like
the premise of you said you would be
there with him till the end and now
things are going south with him as a a
person and you leave so that was the
only thing to me that stood out as like
i still don't have the answer to that
question you know the timing of the
divorce is very weird she left him like
one month before he gets hit with all of
these lawsuits you know what the
lawsuits are
uh he
can you remind me yeah this isn't a quiz
no no it's i i know that he defrauded a
bunch so he was a
lawyer for um like victims in cases
where you like the eric brockovich case
he would like do civil um
class-action lawsuits against like big
companies on behalf of victims who have
been like severely damaged or
otherwise from these big companies one
of them that was a famous case of his
more recently the lion air flight that
had gone down a few years ago it was
like a
boeing plane
lion air is an airline where it's not it
wasn't based um in the us but it was a
flight
that
malfunctioned and went down and everyone
died and he was a lawyer on behalf of
all of the victims the families of the
victims
and
the families of the victims allege that
they never got paid from the money that
was supposed to come from he embezzled
that money there were other victims who
are also coming forward and filing
lawsuits against him they uh you know
some they
were like wronged by companies like in
the gas industry their house exploded
this what like if you watch the and they
want and he kept the money and never
gave it to them yeah he would like he
would leave them like voicemail saying
you know what i'm going to like invest
this money for you it'll be better
you'll get more money and he was
embezzling that money allegedly it's
really it's the worst of the worst
that's crazy right
and he was like this big shot big time
lawyer he was like the guy
so
there's a lot that you know she has to
answer for having been his wife anyway
so she
divorces him a month before all of this
comes to light so it's like did you know
that this was coming to light that's why
you divorced him are you divorcing him
to hide the money that he stole so that
only he's liable but i don't think that
that's true in any sort of way they're
coming for her if she's not i don't
think they're in cahoots on this but or
did you get out like right before the
ship was sinking
and she really you know maintains that
it has nothing to do with any of that
stuff that it was just you know the
marriage between them was no longer
a loving marriage but
it wasn't a loving marriage because of
perhaps these health issues he was
suffering and you said you were going to
be there till the end so i just didn't
feel like she answered that question
why should she have to be there till the
end if he's a criminal
well she won't say she's
she hasn't conceded that he's done these
things she says that she doesn't know
and that she never knew but maybe she
doesn't know and she never knew oh
i understand
so you can't say you don't know and you
never knew
and then also and also say i'm leaving
him because he's a criminal yeah that's
where things get sticky yeah interesting
i wonder if
there's anything
in there like sort of like when you
leave a job a non-disparagement like i
wonder if she speaks ill of him publicly
everything she says on the show
bad good otherwise is you is being used
in court so she has to be so careful
yeah it's being used in her divorce
proceedings and in these legal cases
that are being filed against tom and her
yeah she's in a very difficult so i'm
sure that she legally cannot say
anything
incriminating right but she also has to
do her job and be on the show so what's
very clear at least to me
is that
she she didn't know because
she didn't she didn't know that these
things were happening how would she know
that these things are happening how much
you know that he's defrauding victims
when it's his
he's the lawyer she's not the lawyer
yeah they have different like you don't
share
all of your life's work with your
husband and you're the same like work is
work
uh
but obviously it came to light maybe she
heard a voicemail or something divorced
him but now in these
uh
proceedings she can't talk about it it's
clear as day
so i cracked the case
so okay so in that case then she's
innocent
yeah
the call the call is that she knew that
she was that her husband was defrauding
victims and she was spending his money
per perhaps
and that also like at one point she has
an llc and at one point like in the you
know height of
things he deposited 20 million dollars
into her llc
damn but then she says that he ran her
llc
that
oh
yeah
yeah and it gets sticky yeah i don't
know i don't know either all i'm saying
is from last night i took away from it
like she
don't count her out she's she could be
back
with a vengeance
she's got a lot on the line i think that
she's i think if you know back isn't
back on the show is the call that she's
not gonna be back on the show well if
she gets accused of these crimes and
convicted then yeah no she probably
wouldn't be on the show but if she
doesn't then there's no reason why what
her husband did but theresa stayed on
the show
uh yes and people do like to
oh they do associate the two yes the
difference is that teresa's husband
defrauded the government he was you know
like evading taxes and that is a
different sort of crime for stealing
from orphans and widows and burn victims
for sure um and
it was really like
joe her husband who was doing those
things but i guess why is it
more
joe than tom
well we're figuring we're trying to
figure that out now you're saying that
if it's clear that it was her of course
she's off the show yeah no i don't the
same way i don't think it was her but
i'm just saying i really when all this
stuff was starting to come out household
in the hustler i was like you know that
is it for her
close-up shop i understand but i'm i'm
really seeing now how she can come back
from this
and i still don't i'm still you know i
don't know what to believe in i think
that the courts you know will see what
comes out
but
i think if this reunion was a very
important
conversa like inflection point in this
whole story and i think she's doing a
really good job
wow she you know yeah even if she's not
telling all the truth or she's lying or
this or that like i think she's
she's turning the tide what a tricky
little story right
okay so that was the bulk of the reunion
and anything else that happened was just
like during talks a lot
yeah we know um kathy hilton was on and
she was crying it was really sad and
sweet and i was crying
um just like so she's on this season you
know kyle is her sister
kyle's kathy's sister oh i didn't know
that yeah i thought i knew that they
were related i didn't realize it was her
sister yeah they're sisters and they um
they weren't speaking for like 10 years
because of like kyle doing
this show housewives with kim and like
airing like family dirty laundry which
like
kathy really like doesn't agree with and
they were just like right it's easy not
to want to go on a show when you have a
billion dollars yeah they were just like
crying like for all the lost time and um
just and i think their mom i don't know
when she passed away but i think kathy
really like misses her and it was just
very emotional and um
i think she like struggles with like
what would her mom
think of this or that or
and that's why she was always like hard
on kyle for doing the show and the other
she also did a show called american
woman which was a scripted show about
her childhood and so again kathy's like
please stop
so there's just a lot of history there
but it was but now they're good so
that's good and i don't really recall
anything else of import other than like
lisa arena living for
the amelia scott conversation
but they were just talking about it
yeah because uh and they talked about on
the show they were dating lisa was like
i'm not you know not here for it
meanwhile she's like living for it but
andy asked about the breakup and so we
got some information but that was about
it
then i watched winter house i don't i've
never really watched summer house um
so i'm i i know kyle and amanda because
i watched the first season a little bit
of summer house and like they we've met
them and so i i know them and then i
follow paige so like that's exciting and
i don't know who luke is and sierra is
fabulous and then i know the southern
charm guys austin and craig and then
there's three new cast members so it
felt like it was okay that i didn't know
everyone it was a a mix of people um and
i was really watching because you know
who craig conover is i do and do you
know who paige disorbo is she's from
summerhouse
no okay but i know craig they're now
dating in real life oh they're such a
cute couple and they're both on the show
winter house together so i was like of
course they fell in love on winter house
and that's so amazing so i was like i
have to watch winterhouse to see this
blossoming relationship but no craig
arrives at the winter house with a
girlfriend of 10 months named natalie
who he loves she's not she's not in the
house but like he's spo he's in a
relationship he's not looking at anyone
like i don't he didn't even speak to
paige i was just like what the page and
him are together now yes but apparently
during the whole course of filming
they never got together on the show they
got together after the show interesting
so i'm just like well that's annoying
yeah and anyways like so paige is like
talking to another guy and actually
sierra and um austin are such a cute
couple i'm very much looking forward to
that it's it really felt like i was
watching like jersey shore or something
just like all these strangers put into a
house together it was the first episode
was tough because it was like everyone
you know when you like go on a trip with
people and like the first night just
everyone's like buck wild like drinking
and like
just wanting to make new friends it's
just like a lot of chaotic energy so i
found it to be like a little chaotic
um
and the situation with the rooms was
really funny i don't everyone's like
kyle should have gotten the primary
suite because he planned the trip and
he's it
with his fiancee amanda
but like how could he have planned the
trip when this is a show for bravo like
let's get [ __ ] real nobody he didn't
book the house
so if the other girls wanted to take
that room they should have taken it he
played himself basically there's 10
rooms 12 people all the rooms are pretty
nice but there is one suite that's like
you know the master suite that's better
than all the others kyle just assumed
that would be his because he planned the
trip even though this is a show there
was nothing to plan
um and so then all throughout the day
all the other rooms start getting taken
up and he winds up like in a room now in
the basement where he has to share a
bathroom he and his fiancee have to
share a bathroom with two other girls
and it's like that's really bad but like
you could have taken any other room
i i just i can't i can't relate yikes
yeah
so um where does it take place
stow vermont oh nice so it's nice i do
love you know the
like when did they film wonder house
last winter oh okay so it is during the
winter yes no there's snow and it's a
great vibe the house is just really
stressing me out because it's filthy
already and it's only day two and it's
just stow is awesome yeah
but they need to to clean up the house
like
it's just it's hard to watch weird that
they would film it there though
i think they
must it must have been coveted related
driving yes driving to a destination
that was like not too far from the city
yeah and then kyle also you know grew up
going to stowe i guess that's like how
they're interesting
they're framing all of this but it's you
know it's just a show interesting and
kyle was on
summerhouse yeah
so um so far it's good and it's cute
it's just um
very chaotic
so there was chaos
but it was fun for me because i don't
i got to like meet some of the new
people
and
even like the summer house people who
have not seen like i follow paige but i
have not seen her on tv so she's
literally has the best style like top
five bravo liberty style
and it's a pleasure to watch wow yeah
wow yeah like like to re you know up
there wow
cool
so that's our tv recap that's our show
ben thank you so much for joining us of
course it's been a pleasure we'll be
back tomorrow so if you guys have any
follow-up questions for ben
is there anything i should be watching
tonight there's nothing on so you are
good but we like should we like pick i
know like i'm totally going like a movie
or something going off book should we
pick a movie or should we pick a
tv show or something and watch it and
talk about it is there something topical
oh can we talk about the impeachment so
claudia told us that you're loving
impeachment love
and you know what yeah share your
thoughts but without any spoilers please
impossible okay so then let's watch a
movie okay
um
we don't have to watch a movie
yeah you let me know let's just let's
just watch something
so that i can really
yeah so that on monday we could recap
something together yeah i just want to
be informed on it on the topic okay so
that i don't because otherwise like i
come off and like people are like why do
you say that and it's because i don't
have any information so i'm just like
you know yeah maybe we'll watch like a
documentary or something interesting
blackfish again
amazing documentary
that is a good documentary it's like the
only documentary i've ever seen i think
that's a good weekend assignment so
tonight we'll we'll peruse and we'll
find something that we all could maybe
want to watch and then we'll talk about
it on monday that would be so fun
and other than that thank you so much
for joining us always a pleasure always
thank you for having me always
entertaining i'll see you tomorrow so
great stuff great stuff i think you know
we're we're one for three so far so
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast millennium morning show
where we deliver fast-paced parties
every monday through friday
and there's other stuff to the ending
that i don't really know by heart so if
you made it this far into the episode
society season two
how about you comment a football on our
instagram post photo of me and ben to
commemorate the fact that we have our
winning combo for the super bowl 2022.
love it football we'll see you tomorrow
goodbye bye guys